hi David how are you David Cross
wow-whee your first stop this morning
you are yes well I got the t.o.p first a
second welcome buddy thank you for
having me thank you for being thorough
and mentioning it to me and not coming
in here and starting off on a lie yeah
no I that's not me yeah you're doing
more tour dates you do you really want
to stop and then just finishing up you
just want to do a few more you like I go
through the piers where like I need a
break for a while now oh my god [ __ ] it
I still wanna go out exactly I the
brakes I definitely need the brakes but
then the brakes are too long and but I
def an end date the November 8th show
and in Brooklyn is at BAM is the last
show are you gonna shoot it or I shot it
already
oh you did yeah in Asheville North
Carolina why don't you have an airdate I
don't I haven't even sold it yet I just
I'm gonna I produced it myself and it's
how I did the second last special and
and then I'll shop it around have you
started working on new stuff already so
you kind of know what you're gonna go
into after you're done with this special
after the eighth or no not really I mean
I have a bunch of stuff that I'm doing
now that I didn't do in the first half
of the tour just cuz you know it evolves
on stage and you drop it's and you know
I I don't want to do too much time so I
drop bits here and there as the whole
thing expands and and I have a bunch of
stuff that I can do that I haven't been
doing that I can work on and make better
for the next tour but the worst thought
was when you shoot something and then
you have like a month or two left on the
tour and then you start adding and
tagging better like oh [ __ ] well listen
dude do what I've been doing the last
couple things is I I shoot midway
through the tour cuz then I know this
stuff is really it's really settled it's
it's bill it's way better than it was I
fine-tuned it you know you work on it
every night and then because it keeps
evolving then I audio record the last
show or one of the last shows it's what
are you do the last two times and then I
called you or yeah release a CD yeah
which is the same name or a variation of
the same name but it has you know
five percent of the material is
different and it's it takes those bits
whereas like oh man I wish I wish I had
said this thing cuz there was like word
just the I mean you guys know it's just
like the subtlest thing that changes it
makes it better that you've discovered
one night on stage see I like to drop it
and then that 25% extra I would have now
twenty five percent of a new one done I
guess yeah there's I mean some of that
too you know you're smarter than you can
sell the CD yeah you my last one to
Netflix when didn't get put out on CD I
mean I could about like then they're
gonna open it who cares yeah well I made
I worked into the deal that I would be
able to do this cuz I've done it a
couple times like that well you can
release it and then release the lot you
know the show the tape live thing that
you're watching and then I retain the
rights to the audio which will be you
know roughly 25% different and then do
you kind of in your head know which joke
for you counts you know what I mean like
meaning like like the the version that
has the tag that's the real joke in my
head or the version or you know what I
like the first version better in
hindsight that's the real one I usually
like the the improved new and improved
one yeah you know always the way it is
no one ever makes a joke worse after
they shoot it like once the joke has
been filmed it only improves enter that
you don't like go back to the audio
version just because the shitty luck and
the odds like of course I've came up
with a much better tag yeah you know
right next night that's why I do a lot
of crowd work when I'm done
like once I shoot something if I have
like two months left on the tour I'll
start doing crowd work which will start
getting me into new material bits and I
could just start it just because I can't
handle doing something and going I
filmed it and it's much better now it
just drives me crazy
so you start building the next special I
try to immediately whether somebody
wants it or not it just it helps keep me
feel like aren't I'm doing but I didn't
do that this time so now I'm just kind
of floundering like an [ __ ] I get
that yeah like a super rich guy like
billionaire guy who will just be the guy
who buys your specials you know and then
do it for him do it I said the Jeff
Bezos every year I've never heard back
rich people don't give a [ __ ] out it's
got to be edible arrangements I know
that's those guys they they don't give a
[ __ ] about flowers or soaps or lotions
it's got to be pineapple mango car
into like a teddy bear or something like
that's the only thing they respond it's
funny I just sent one of those those are
awesome thoughtless gifts edible
arrangements throw money at wait wait I
have to tell you this is absolutely true
I several years ago I was living in this
you know a loft building co-op condo in
in Dumbo and and this I said this this
tragic event happened for this woman who
lived there her husband young young
couple two very young kids and the
husband died unexpectedly tragically and
then it was you know is the in the news
actually and was all over the building
and I came in I want to say it was two
days later after this thing happened
this awful terrible tragedy and at the
desk was an edible arrangement for this
woman I could see the card uh-huh you
know on your on her loss a tragedy that
you can barely wrap your head around
yeah your whole life is different and
awful and you got two little kids and
somebody sending a fruit plate it's kind
of this you know gaiety theme you know
here's you know and that stuff also goes
bad pretty quickly so it's like better
eat that pie I don't really have an
appetite at the moment well it's not
going to eat itself exactly it really is
like I feel like an edible arrangement
is it's a thoughtless gift you said I
just sent one to a friend who did me a
big favor
when I just throw money at it it screams
thoughtlessness like nobody ever gets an
edible arrangement going like oh they
really thought highly of me I don't care
where you get one though you just like
[ __ ] this is awesome I'm going to eat
it but like I know it's thoughtless but
I still it's delicious
so I [ __ ] enjoy it is that what you
do when you get a net concord grapes
yeah on court great delicious this mango
is not a stick [ __ ] I'm gonna eat it
right
berries are awesome you know I think
about them ever until someone sends one
to you ya know I've never looked at an
edible arrangement and gone like this
this is awesome I go like why would they
let the person who buys it for
themselves sends it to themselves writes
a note you know you're doing good keep
you know that there is somebody that
just they just enjoy the taste they just
like edible arrangements and they feel
silly just ordering it without a card so
they write it to themselves and
something encouraged a no way overpriced
fruit no no they do come on time though
I got the receipt by my friend sent me a
picture here's all you should know well
yeah yeah and maybe you don't even know
you're not aware of the edible
arrangement concept and you just see it
initially as an arrangement like well I
don't need a [ __ ] arrangement oh wait
you can eat it
if flowers is a [ __ ] gift that's a [ __ ]
gift unless they're edible flowers then
I'm phenomenal right but something that
you could enjoy like I just don't want
something pointless that I can't enjoy
you can't enjoy flowers no but you can't
enjoy because you you can't enjoy scent
but you can't enjoy taste not enjoy
tasting interesting flowers might bring
in this the the other sense into it
scent is even bigger for me than tasty
Wow then what's wrong with flowers for a
week what is edible arrangements last
forever it's a good point they last even
less my theory is flawed cookies by
design is good to start sample you're 17
I didn't know that about you yeah well
technically was 17 was literally the
week before my 18th birthday but yeah
the first time I did I went to an open
mic night 17 years old and Sandy Springs
Georgia a suburb of Atlanta punchline
and the worst the worst thing that could
ever happen happened which is I killed
in a in a like if you saw it in a movie
it was ridiculous first time I ever went
on and my acne you know the stuff I was
doing was really [ __ ] e ethereal
kind of when I was heavily influenced by
Andy Kaufman and Steve Martin and Steven
Wright and that kind of yeah that kind
of dryness and weirdness and there's
nothing you could grab on to
was just a weird weird for weird sake
and um and I killed and I and I remember
saying up the red lights on I gotta go
and people like if you cast it you know
people like no you keep them let them
study whatever and and then the isn't
that by the way isn't that the thing
you're not supposed to do if there's
another comic after you going like ah
the red lights on they're making me mean
like that I totally said it like I just
a fact it was a fact oh my god and I had
no ending I had no you know I had well
here comes the closer I mean I've never
been on stage before and and and then
the the host it was from New York so
everybody looked looked up to him was
like hey well that kids got something
going on or whatever it was and and I
walked out of there thinking I'm the
most amazing comedy ever lived this is
amazing holy [ __ ] I was born to do this
star was born the next year I mean
there's like 20 times I set foot on
stage it just it got the you know the
response of killing upfront killing like
that on the first time is is really bad
because it did get your expectation that
this is what it was I was confused I
didn't know what was happening and this
is the same set I did and you're even
saying that as a you know like just
dying like I don't what I just did this
last week and it was great when you say
that yeah it was it was a bizarre thing
to go through so when that happens at
first do you go like oh man I'm gonna be
one of those comics that just never
bombs I'm just gonna do this yeah every
time that that is that's what you think
you know like boy this material kills my
choices were all the right choices and
they got it and I my personality came
out on state whatever and then and I
mean literally just bombing or the next
yeah yeah wait here
when's the last time you had or maybe
you can't remember cuz you know doing it
in front of people who are there to see
you
you're not gonna bomb that often I mean
I might have jokes that don't work but
it's been a while yeah but when you go
up like do it a twenty-minute spot
somewhere and just [ __ ] bomb and you
can't get out of it
like after 25 years you should be able
to get out of it then this
times like I can't get out of this I'm
just bombing yeah well when if if
several years have gone by cuz you know
I'll be working on other projects and
and then I jump on a show because you
want it you just have that thing inside
you that makes you want to get back up
on stage and you don't really have that
much material and and part of what I do
is you know kind of right on stage and I
just I don't sit and write jokes and
stuff and and the ideas that you had are
clearly not coming to any you thought
this would be three minutes and it's
literally about 17 seconds and you have
nothing you thought Oh riff on this on
stage and then you've got 20 minutes and
it's just it's a it's a sinking awful
feeling and people know who you are yeah
you know and they've had an expectation
of something and they're just not
delivering but it's kind of thrilling to
see somebody that's like that experience
and see it like oh boy this will be a
treat to watch them just sure freak I'm
completely I'm gonna dick it's great I
respect Damon Wayans a lot because I've
watched Damon eat his dick for 50
minutes and not 505 Oh
I mean bomb and up there working out
divorce whatever he was doing but he was
working out material of one o'clock in
the morning at the Comedy Cellar and he
didn't give a [ __ ] and I really
respected that I'm like this guy who is
really famous can go up there and work
it out this way I mean that's the way to
do I think there's a there's a
difference so yeah when you're when
you're working stuff out and people know
it and you gotta yeah there has to be
some sort of forgiveness there you know
if you're going if you're bombing with
you know tried and true test and
material that's a that's a even worse
feeling it's you gotta do an hour you
know especially if you're trying to get
out of it like again when you're doing a
spot and you're trying material and it's
not working like alright let me use this
and this will you know write the ship
and then we'll do the new [ __ ] again and
that doesn't rent oh yes a half walked a
lot really in my life sure yeah it
hasn't happened in a while we're nothing
but if it's gonna happen to me it'll
usually happen at the village
underground which is the sellers sister
club around the corner because that's
not the it's a great club but for me
it's not as good as the cellar so if I'm
gonna have one of those it'll be there
and I can feel it that's an advertising
technique right now people are gonna be
lining up to go see that show
bombing ya see him at the cellar I wanna
see ya eating his dick
that really is Colin does the fat black
pussycat is we're like well you guys
will go work out an hour there it's a
small like an 80 seat room and column
was talking about how apparently a lot
of people in front of him really bomb
really and you've sung a Bob Kelly
bombing he's probably doesn't like that
much does he
to watch Bob Kelly you twice want to get
friends bomb in front of you what's
better
do you take pleasure in that watching
your friends bomb like I'm not like on a
haha this is bad for you but I mean sure
there's a there's it's it's fun because
you know it's they're pros and it's
temporary and that's in that moment but
they're not going to be too emotionally
scarred by it they're not like in year
one you know or year two of their career
where it's really gonna have a you know
debilitating effect but it's so it is
kind of fun it's like do you get angry
when you bought like this times we're
all walking out of the room and I'll do
the set I'll be like [ __ ] I hated those
feet like do you get that or you yeah I
mean I think I'm pretty good at at going
when something you know when it's a it's
a bad set either going well that was me
that was my fault or that was you know
the room added to that some some rooms
are just bad to do comedy and and then
sometimes it's it's the audience and I
think I'm pretty good at that but when I
when I think it's just the audience and
there's no other factors and yeah [ __ ]
those people the comic strip wasn't
always never great in and that's a club
that everybody loved doing on 82nd and
second everyone killed in the comic
strip and I would go on there and
[ __ ] bomb time after time I never did
well in that room I remember one of my
favorite things was when I saw you at
that Club I think it was in Los Angeles
I think and and you were getting upset
because you were on stage and there was
this couple that obviously was not into
the improv yeah yeah it would they were
not into the show at all
like everybody was laughing stuff these
two people that were in the front row
and like halfway through the show you
were like guys like what's wrong here
like what's the problem what are you
saying who they were talking to each
other and and we realized that they went
into the wrong room they're in the wrong
show so I hated them but I was like all
right you know this is not what you came
to see yes
the other thing that almost every comic
has that susceptibility to you know
you're doing a you know a 2,000 seat
theater and it's killing but you can see
you know left side six throw in four
seats it has those people don't like you
and that's all you're [ __ ] thinking
about were you bucking people will you
confront it like when you notice there's
one person right there I need to talk to
that maybe if I think I can if it's you
know if I think I can get some jokes out
of it right but not just out of likey
not that it's lighter I don't either
even because simply like if they're just
quietly hating my guts well I mean I all
I ask him to do is laugh or not laughs I
can't they're not disturbing anybody
they have every right to think I stink
but you know that you're the only one
who notices it's not like anybody else
in the room you know but you can feel it
it's almost like it's like a bump in the
air like when you're looking you're
trying to look past them and your face
just going over it like you feel the
[ __ ] stare coming up at you it's
really uncomfortable but it's really
weird and this isn't just for comedy but
when you when you watch a performer snap
and get angry and stop you know just
halt their show because of a
misperception to which I've seen I
remember going to see Joe Jackson when I
was like teenager in Atlanta and he was
at the Fox Theater and he can't he'd
like part of his set was kind of a slow
down he sent the band off and he was
gonna do some acoustic stuff or whatever
and he came downstage and he said he had
a beer and he said or I think he had a
piano rolled it doesn't matter but
anyway he he said he said something and
then somebody in the audience which we
could all hear yelled something about
guitars and he thought somebody said or
no it was about his beer and he thought
somebody said guitars and he went off he
just stopped and screamed at this guy
for suggesting he bring guitars I've
been playing this [ __ ] thing and he
was totally wrong beer about his beer
that he sat on a piano or something
and it was the weirdest thing and he
just it just the whole rest of the show
is like oh yeah awkward because then you
realized like everybody in the audience
no it's like I didn't say anything about
guitars and now we all know this
comedian is super sensitive about
concerns yeah yeah yeah he's a comedian
no he's not comedian was a performer oh
boy um love represent song no no that
was Jackson Browne Oh Jackson my god
wait I was like a new wave II new wave
era but we all like we can't enjoy the
songs anymore because now we know you're
super sensitive about guitars dude and
we know you're and we know you're you
know you've been put off for the rest of
the show and it's just weird and right
attention and no one can explain it so
no he didn't say that Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe wait Joe I love when [ __ ] like
I've seen kiss do it I love him
performers will stop a performance these
laser pointers in the audience and then
a guy will actually stop and point the
person out and humiliate them that I
kind of like when bands do that do
people still do that thing not probably
as much but there's a lot of people that
would do that [ __ ] back in the day I'll
write em everywhere yes yeah just go up
a point at the guy on his face yeah Paul
Stanley went on a rant one time about
laser pointer yeah I've also seen guys
threaten if he does that again kick his
ass I'm like you're out of your you're
begging for a lawsuit
you're on stage asking someone to crowd
to get beat up yeah I think Dave Grohl
my favorite stoppage was Dave Grohl like
he saw a fight
starting in his audience and he just
starts yelling at him and he goes we
didn't come to fight we came to dance
[ __ ] no it's like just to get
the vibe back going again did it work
yeah the one guy got kicked out and
everybody was like [ __ ] yeah we don't
know that would motivate me at all the
best of that kind of stuff I saw was I
wouldn't saw tool in Tijuana early early
on and their audience was like really
aggro was almost all guys aggro
shirtless and there was this I couldn't
tell what was happening but there was a
[ __ ] happening in front and he stopped
and he just like kind of bent down and
went on this whole kind of soft-spoken
but angry about how home
they were and why don't you guys just go
[ __ ] and all this stuff it was really
effective and really cool and then went
back into the song and it was pretty
great it's amazing how's your I know you
guys are doing another season for
Arrested Development is that that's not
the one you shot before this is a new
season shot right no no or is that the
same season yeah we shot the whatever
was 16 episodes and then they broke it
to to 8 episode series so it's like five
and a half about six or five and a half
or whatever it's the same we all shot it
at once and they just aired the first
date and then the second date come out I
think early so you all you haven't had
to go back and shoot since the whole
thing is all good yeah that's already
done that's funny but I mean Arrested
Development kind of did a similar thing
to what you're talking about with the
comedy when they realized like ha that
that season that came out for Netflix we
didn't really like it let's just redo
the season
let's just remix the whole season and it
took him uh I think that was kind of in
there kind of I think they had that idea
ready to go I mean it took a long long
time and a lot of effort to do that yeah
but I think that was an idea that they
had thought that was potentially if this
doesn't work so yeah they took a lot of
time and so now it's if you can watch it
kind of chronologically you know do you
tour internationally or you just stay in
the States
I do Europe I just got back from there a
couple weeks ago I did very very brief
truncated version not like I did last
time because I have a kid now and I that
was the longest I've been away from her
since she was born
how old 20 months but when I do my set
and if you're listening to this and
you're gonna go see my shows she's one
years old and I try I tried one or two
shows I tried to because I have this
real weird thing about being honest and
I can't lie I can't even exaggerate I
don't like it it's just I don't
weird thing with it but so I tried to do
the set where I was honest about and it
just doesn't work
she's 16 months and but yeah exactly
exactly
know the jokes are stand as they were
when they were written but yeah but
anyway I I and I did something that I
hate doing which is flu in day of show I
hate it cuz so much can go wrong and
there's nothing worse than traveling all
day and then running up onstage and
you're just not it sucks like the way
it's fun it's a terrifying tense filled
experience it's uh it's awful and I try
I try to avoid it but because I didn't
want to be away for so long I I took the
red-eye into Manchester where my first
show was in England and then in the and
I had and I've got this down to a
science because I do it a lot I know
when to start drinking I got it all down
and I I'm sorry I can hear that's my
phone I put it on silent that's it's
tickling my balls anyway so I knew I
know when to start drinking I know when
to stop I've got it all down when I can
get some sleep how much sleep I'll get
then I could take a nap at like you know
11:00 and and I'll be good but the
flight was delayed by like an hour and
so I was like oh so I started drinking I
go I got this then the flight was
delayed they're like alright so I had
some more drinks and then I just sort of
then we got on the plane and then we had
a sit on the tarmac for an hour so now
my whole thing is all [ __ ] up then we
got in the air I was like okay I got a
slam to drinks and I go to sleep to make
up for the time and then so I drink some
more and like now I can go to sleep and
then they make this announcement others
your pilot run and good news is we were
sorry for that delay but good news is we
will be able to make up the time in the
air we're gonna have a super short
flight today and planer no yeah well if
I drink a lot yeah so I drink and you
know take some pills whatever and
and then I was just a mess when I got in
it was like it was all shot and and I
was a I was a mess that night
and but the audience was super cool and
I explained what my situation was and
they could not have been better
you told them all that like look the
schedule got all fun yeah yes exactly I
haven't slept I don't know what time it
is I don't know who you are I don't know
who I am
and I was definitely a little rusty too
because I taken two weeks off and did
the that part of the North American tour
and but they were awesome
England is really good for me I loved it
I won't do it once I did two nights in
London and what a mansion I loved it it
was one where did you play it was some I
forget the theaters I was uh I honestly
don't remember the [ __ ] no memory
whatsoever it the one in my one of
Manchester almost looked like a college
room I know she's a theater that would
had seating going up which does not help
and I know so edit theater seating dance
hall theater so it was like a weird
don't remember which is the theater that
has theater seating yes exactly that was
that's pretty much what I just said was
the dance it was like this it's like a
dance studio place where they have shows
sometimes the other one is like the
there Oh to the adjunct thing and they
put seats out no Jim Norton Manchester's
dance house that's the place I was
thinking of yeah I don't remember but
anyway I loved it and I loved going over
there Oh what it was it was the dance
house I'm getting in my ear that where I
was yes okay thank ya it's yeah it was
cool and the people are great
and England's the UK in general is
really good for me what's worse than
when you're walking on and you're like I
feel like lightheaded I can't I feel
like I'm not rested I'm [ __ ] up this
is gonna be terrible
dude I was in such a weird state of mind
and yeah it's but you just be honest and
you talk about it and again they were
I've done a number shows there too so I
think it wasn't like my first right
there and I think you know had people
that had come and see me a number of
times before so there was that kind of
forgiveness but it was fun you mean to
try to have fun with it you know it was
it was good do you ever have to puke
onstage I
a thing where I was doing this roast it
was I was psyching my sister part 2003 I
was getting really like dizzy and
lightheaded on stage and I feel like I
had throw up and at one point I used to
have to have a bucket put on the side of
the stage where or I'd find a place to
like if I puke that's why I'm gonna go
puke it was this crazy lunch totally did
it totally psychologically did it to not
do it yes if you if you knew the butt
bucket wasn't there then you'd puke then
I felt like I was gonna puke I don't
have to walk off once to puke at the
cellar I ate too many [ __ ] cream
puffs in a row Bob Kelly was hosting and
I was like I'm gonna vomit I said get
Bob down and he came back down and I
went and vomited and came back on but
that was a stellar show but this these
were like headline shows and in like the
the [ __ ] without the the theatre in
Boston's it was it was a really great
with that [ __ ] Theatre in Boston here
remember any 12 mm she's like - that is
this back 2003 was it - Charles Theatre
no because no Orpheum there you go the
Ernest it's been many years - no I got
out so excited about that stage in the
Orpheum holding on to the stool I'm like
I'm gonna [ __ ] pass out it was just
as crazy like two-year period I went
through I kept thinking I was in a faint
or you get sick Wow
it's [ __ ] awful a weird guy little
[ __ ] complaining so I don't know how
you wanted that show I guess is the
point